[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce dixième
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo 26 minutes pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans votre département
au sommaire de ce vendredi 15 novembre
dans le cadre de ses rencontres du
territoire le département des yvelines a
souhaité mettre en avant l' équité
sociale et territoriale avec une aide
aux collégiens et aux quartiers nous
avons super bédié à plaisir de projets
présents dans les yvelines ont été
retenus finaliste pour le prix google
maps challenge nous recevront en plateau
la responsable du centre yves binois de
wever 3 qui nous présentera l'un de ses
projets andy portes sièges
le projet de règlement local de
publicité intercommunale voté le 1er
anniversaire et gilet jaune chamonix qui
fait concurrence à la colline
d'elancourt pour les jeux olympiques
2024 nous ferons le tour de ceux qui a
rythmé les yvelines cette semaine
le collectif résistance à l'agression
publicitaire a interpellé les élus du
conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines jeudi soir en
effet le projet de règlement local de
publicité intercommunes intercommunale
était inscrit à l'ordre du jour dans la
semaine le collectif a remis une
pétition signée d'un millier de
personnes au rapporteur du projet
grégory gary astier il s'oppose
notamment à l'autorisation
d'installation d'écrans numériques
publicitaires l'agglomération a réalisé
longue concertation depuis l'évocation
de ce projet en 2018 et prend en compte
la volonté de protection de
l'environnement des habitants
le projet a donc été votée avec quarante
et une voix pour 8 contre et 16
abstentions et une enquête publique sera
menée au mois de mai avant l'arrêté
définitif du règlement réaction au micro
de nicolas landry il ya des choses qui
ont progressé dans le règlement entre ce
qui nous avait été proposé l'année
dernière et ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui à
des choses qui ont progressé il ya des
choses qui pourraient être encore mieux
les écrans numériques on vient d'en
parler l'extinction du mobilier urbain
la nuit par exemple qui pourrait très
bien après
après les passages des bus les abris de
bus ont pu besoin d'être éclairés les
différentes installations de sucettes
dans la ville pourrait aussi être
éteinte la nuit on a trouvé un juste
milieu je pense il faut penser à la
qualité de la vie à tous ces panneaux
qui sont sur les routes bon pied en même
temps faut pas pénaliser les entreprises
surtout à saint quentin on a on a des
dix sept mille entreprises voilà il faut
soit on a à peu près trouvé un équilibre
[Musique]
le département par l'intermédiaire de
son président pierre bel il poursuit ses
rencontres du territoire après une
première menée à rambouillet autour du
soutien aux communes le déplacement
portait cette fois sur l'équité sociale
et territoriale à travers l'aide aux
collégiens et aux quartiers mélanie
poker et nicolas landry la culture en
jeu d'égalité pour le département les
yvelines remettait hier un chèque de
3000 euros aux équipes pédagogiques du
collège plaisir wa blaise pascal
un montant qui se traduit par des cartes
lire pour le futur salon histoire de
lire de versailles
nous savons tous que l'ifa les l'origine
famille l'origine sociale des familles
détermine souvent les parcours des
élèves pas toujours mais c'est souvent
le cas bien entendu et on le sait depuis
nombreuses années dix élèves ne vont pas
à paris par exemple ne vont pas à
versailles
si on va pas si nous n'avons pas des
projets à leur proposer n'y vont pas
donc et bien voilà tous ces projets font
que nous pouvons les accompagner puisque
son financement est bien le collège
serait fortement enfin fort démuni 160
millions d'euros sont consacrés aux
collèges publics et privés du
département comme dix neuf autres
établissements blaise pascal est inscrit
en réseau d'éducation prioritaire
nous souhaitons que les collectivités
aujourd'hui et tout le même je dirais
mais les mêmes apports positifs pour
pouvoir avancer
on a des collectivités qui sont mieux
dotés que d'autres on a des
collectivités plus en difficulté que
d'autres en tout cas on a aujourd'hui la
nécessité et le besoin d'avoir cet
accompagnement la des départements et je
crois que le département cherche à
trouver une capacité pour accompagner
que ce soit la ruralité que ce soit les
villes qui sont encore en transformation
c'est un canton dont les villes sont
encore en devenir
parce que elles ne sont pas stabilisés
elles sont pas stabilisés une ville
comme versailles est une ville achevée
on la retouche à la marge plaisir c'est
une ville qui se construit encore
plaisir à une originalité c'est que il
ya un quartier d'habitat social qui est
en plein centre ville ça n'existe dans
aucune autre ville désigne un quartier
social qui s'est vu doté d'une enveloppe
de 65 millions d'euros pour une
rénovation en profondeur les travaux
valley beau doivent commencer en début
d'année 2020 un forum d'entreprises à
l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs basée à
montigny le bretonneux l'organisait de
jeudi à vendredi à destination de ses
étudiants en fin de cycle en 4e et 5e
années stands conférences et speed
networking
une trentaine d'entreprises étaient
présentes le but ce les aider dans leur
projet professionnel et rencontrer les
acteurs de leur secteur et les
transports avec la fénière la finalité
de trouver un stage ou un emploi
propos recueillis par nicolas landry ya
un objectif vis à vis des étudiants
comme un objectif vis-à-vis des
entreprises c'est vraiment cette
rencontre gagnant gagnant les
entreprises ont besoin de recruter des
talents et les talons besoin d'être
recruté de savoir un peu de quoi sont
faits les entreprises donc c'est un
endroit qui t'a c'est assez convivial et
assez peu formalisés où on peut rentrer
en direct avec soin les rh choix des
alumni des différentes entreprises qui
permettent de 2 200 tirs
j'ai déjà sentir l'un l'autre pour voir
s'il ya une appétence possible depuis
plusieurs années google organise un prix
qui récompense un projet inclusif liés
au numérique le google impact challenge
dix projets sont retenus finalistes et
soumis au vote du public puis d'un jury
le grand gagnant peut remporter jusqu'à
six cent mille euros et un
accompagnement pour la réalisation de
son projet pour la session 2010 9 le
vote du public et chloé nous connaîtrons
les noms des quatre grands gagnants le
19 novembre lors d'une cérémonie parmi
les dix finalistes web for 3 pour son
projet andy fort challenge
marie-france palombes à vous avez vous
êtes avec nous vos joueurs bonjour alors
vous êtes la responsable du stand
rouette porte 3 yvelines alors tout
d'abord est ce que vous nous expliquer
ce qu'est cette structure web pour 3
alors force trois aînés en 2014
c'est un centre de formation qui est
dédié au numérique le numérique c'est 80
mille emplois qui ne sont pas encore
pourvus
donc notre président alain soulignac ray
wise force 3 en 2014 et s'est dédié à
l'inclusion afin que tout le monde
puisse se former aux métiers du
numérique puisqu'il est porteur de
différents métiers donc sur les yvelines
j'ai deux antennes une aux mureaux une
attrape mais en tout nous sommes quand
même 50 écoles déployés à l'étranger
notamment mayotte la guadeloupe et dans
toute la france parie donc lille lyon le
sud suivi le sud ouest 50 écoles pour
répondre aux besoins du numérique de
tous les publics des personnes en
reconversion des autodidactes
d après cette formation où on a 90 % de
sorties positives
de nos stagiaires vers des cdd et des
cdi vers l'entrepreneuriat le freelance
ou bien le contrat en alternance et donc
je reviens au prix donc secret auquel
vous avez participé avec le projet andy
forte chute est-ce que vous expliquer un
peu en quoi cela consiste
alors on a répondu donc cet été à ce
concours puisque on s'est fait un
constat nous on a déjà formé 50
personnes handicapées dans nos sessions
et nos sessions spécifiques paris lille
lyon le 94
ça représente 75 % de cdi à la clé
donc on s'est dit il ya énormément de
personnes des milliers de personnes
handicapées qui n'ont pas de qui n'ont
pas d'emploi
donc nous on peut adapter des formations
donc on a répondu à ce concours
nous sommes donc ravis et fiers d'être
d'être finaliste et on a donc conçu une
formation adaptée accessible et pour que
tous les handicaps et réussissent donc
ce sera que je vous dise pas de bêtises
mille personnes formées de façon
verrouillée avec un ancrage mémorielle
et donc en face à face pédagogique
ils auront aussi du replay et
l'information à distance pour vraiment
que tous les handicapés puissent
bénéficier de cette formation et qui
pilote le projet alors le projet et puis
ils ont piloté par l'équipe ford 3 donc
qui est vraiment tout ce qui est projet
inclusif et c'est vraiment la dn2 web
force 3
donc on est une équipe on a une équipe
en pédagogie on a deux directeur général
on a notre président et nous allons donc
sur chaque site pouvoir former et monter
des classes dédiées à ces handicapés
alors vous êtes est parti du constat que
les personnes en situation de handicap
je recherche de l'emploi en français
sont plus de 500 mille personnes
aujourd'hui l'inclusion handicap dans
les entreprises a justement fait l'objet
d'un manifeste cette semaine lors du
salon du handicap
une centaine d'entreprises françaises
vont signer c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour oui c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
qu'on ne peut pas former si on n'a pas
de d'entreprise derrière on est vraiment
lié
ou monde de l'entreprise donc elle la
place dans le numérique on l'a vu sur
nos personnes donc rqth qui ont une
reconnaissance de travailleur handicapé
ça mène à l'emploi ça 75 % d'insertion
de sorties positives c'est énorme mais
effectivement il faut qu'on ait les
entreprises donc si l'état donne des
avantages et favorise ce ces entreprises
qui vont accueillir des handicapés et
ben voilà on pourra faire plus que ça
mouais si vous gagnez le gouvernail
challenge qu'est ce que ça change ça
change ça nous donnera la possibilité
nous on pense vraiment un e stagiaire
pourra former on a vraiment des groupes
hétérogènes avec des vécus c'est une
vraie richesse
donc pour nous ce qui va changer basse
et de pouvoir plus facilement monter ce
genre de formation puisque on le sait le
nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent donc on
pourrait faire plein de choses mais
voilà si on n'a pas le financement et
ben ce sont des des projets qui végète
très bien merci marie france pas
lombarde est venu sur notre plateau donc
on vous souhaite bonne chance pour le 17
au 19 novembre à ses doigts on va
regarder ça attentivement je précise
quand même qu'un autre projet présent
dans les yvelines est en lice il s'agit
de momentum 2 o'clock des ateliers hante
les présentiel pour initier les jeunes
aux métiers du numérique
[Musique]
le 17 novembre 2018 le mouvement des
gilets jaunes débuter contre la hausse
du prix du carburant et la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat des revendications
élargit aujourd'hui aux inégalités
sociales et fiscales
pourtant les manifestations faibli dans
un contexte de nombreuses grèves contre
les réformes en cours comme le régime de
retraite ou pour manifester un
épuisement général avec par exemple les
hôpitaux cette semaine mercredi nous
recevions de gilet jaune illinois pour
dresser un bilan un an après la colère
est toujours présente un an après
puisqu'on n'a pas l'impression d'avoir
obtenu les réponses qu'on attendait on
n'a même pas l'impression d'avoir été
entendu du tout voilà pour preuve il ya
un courrier qui a été envoyé à monsieur
macron directement le 29 octobre par
priscilla lui deux skiffs à olizy
lellouche
et puis d'autres personnes demandant une
rencontre avec le président pour qu'on
puisse parler des revendications
notamment la plateforme du vrai débat
une plateforme où il ya eu plus d'un
million de votes et aucune réponse n'a
été apportée à ce jour
après deux ans de mandat le conseil
municipal des jeunes de montigny le
bretonneux tenait sa dernière séance
plénière mercredi soir
l'occasion de faire un bilan et de
susciter des envies de candidature chez
leurs camarades pour les prochaines
élections
dernière séance plénière pour les 18
membres du conseil municipal des jeunes
de montigny-le-bretonneux
après deux ans de mandat ils dressent
leur bilan de cette expérience citoyenne
on a amené lui ni dès le tournoi tout
pub le led
le rallye citoyen et on a fait toutes
les commémorations du 11 novembre et du
8 mai un mandat qui lui a donné le goût
de l'engagement il là ne se représentera
pas mais il compte bien intégrer un
collectif de jeunes défenseurs du climat
pour leur vie future c'est ce qu'on
disait c'est très enrichissant et sacré
en fait une ville où chacun peut
s'impliquer à sa mesure sur différents
sujets et c'est plus passionnant le cmj
existe depuis 30 ans à montigny le
bretonneux venir à bout des projets
s'impliquer dans la vie locale et
citoyenne
c'est aussi les moyens de prendre
confiance en soi et grandir entre jeunes
encadrés par une coordinatrice
j'ai appris déjà m'affirmer
parce qu'avant j'étais assez timide j'ai
pu partager mes idées avec les autres
sans avoir spécialement à être coupés on
a tous pu s'entendre vraiment sont deux
années qui ont été pleines de jouer à
plein de bonheur plein d'apprentissage
et c'est qu'elles sont deux années qui
m'ont beaucoup plu manon compte bien
renouveler l'expérience et présentera sa
candidature pour un prochain mandat
ouvert à tous les jeunes du cm2 à la
seconde vous avez jusqu'au 25 novembre
pour remplir votre dossier et leur
apporter en mairie ou au pôle jeunesse
à vous ensuite de convaincre durant
votre campagne avant les élections qui
se dérouleront dans les établissements
scolaires de la ville du 9 au 13
décembre
on ouvre une large page cyclisme
récemment titré champion du monde quant
à la farga réuni certains de ses
coéquipiers de l'équipe de france pour
former la nouvelle équipe de wc skyteam
vous sert florian g beau melvin
landerneau et quentin caleyron
défendront les couleurs du club d'el en
cours avec pour objectif de devenir la
première équipe professionnelle de
cyclisme sur piste
mathilde de 2010 était au lancement de
phase i à tokyo 2020
bien sûr il ya plusieurs étapes avant
tokyo il ya les coupes du monde il y
aura les championnats du monde
et puis après tokyo n'a encore les
championnats de france encore des
championnats du monde pour nous conduire
jusqu'en 2024
l'apothéose doivent faire avec cette
équipe en 2024 sur les terres du vc
skyteam vous sert on reste dans le
cyclisme et dans cette perspective des
jeux olympiques de 2024 avec cette fois
du vtt les épreuves devraient se
dérouler sur la colline d'elancourt
point culminant de l'île de france
projet validé par le comité olympique
mais la donne a peut être changé dans la
tête des organisateurs
le site poserait un problème
environnemental et des voix s'élèvent
contre le coût des travaux
le niveau de difficulté de la colline
d'elancourt pose également des questions
la commune de chamonix espère profiter
de cette incertitude et serait candidate
pour accueillir l'épreuve
on écoute les différentes réactions
recueillies par michael et demi d'euros
et nicolas d'andré légion quand vous
égayer une conviction
voilà vous remettez pas en cause et vous
refaites pas une deuxième compétition
parce que j'ai un copain qui est carré
bien aimé aussi avoir religieux ou burqa
une compétition entre les communes c'est
vrai les 50 1 à 4 sites olympiques bien
sûr que ça ça fait ça fait des jaloux on
le sait mais on assume en tout cas voilà
vous inquiétez pas c'est un très beau
projet attendons les prochaines les
prochaines orientations
c'est un circuit exceptionnel donc c'est
sûr que pour nous pour le club ce serait
une superbe récompense mais
je pense que saint quentin en yvelines
ne cessera pas faire un monde de
cyclisme qui est en deuil et raymond
poulidor est décédé dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi à l'âge de 83 ans
l'ancien coureur cycliste était
hospitalisé depuis le 8 octobre en
raison d'une grande fatigue
même s'il n'a jamais gagné le tour de
france poupe comme il était surnommé
jouissait d'une grande popularité en
france
nous l'avions rencontré à plusieurs
reprises dernier passage en date dans
les yvelines en mars à la foire de
chatou dédicaces auprès du public
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait et
ensuite la réaction du président de la
fédération française de cyclisme
basée à montigny le bretonneux
on retrace évidemment ensemble en
paroles l'ensemble de ma carrière et la
conversation revient souvent avec
jacques anquetil qui est toujours
présent ce fameux duel avec jacques
anquetil et toujours pose la question
comment se fait-il vous n'avez pas gagné
plusieurs tours de france c'est une
grande tristesse et le sentiment de
perdre vraiment quelqu'un de la famille
du cyclisme parce que raymond poulidor
été très pesant encore dans notre
cycliste travers les représentations
qu'ils pouvaient faire dans les
manifestations dans sur le tour de
france à plein d'endroits on avait de
multiples occasions de croiser raymond
poulidor et à chaque fois de mesurer à
quel point le sport cycliste avait pu
être transcendée par par sa popularité
c'était juste incroyable de voir 40 50
ans après sa carrière
comment de partout où il passait il
était toujours aussi aimer toujours
aussi sollicités et finalement toujours
aussi connu de la culture à présent 87
sites sont aujourd'hui labellisé
patrimoine d'intérêt de la région ile de
france
un label pour préserver ces sites non
protégé depuis le mois de septembre
saint quentin en yvelines en compte
trois la perspective de marta pan
méthadone ici mercado et l'apport de
paradis de piotr kowalski mélanie poké
vous les présente
elle vous fait entrer dans saint quentin
en yvelines depuis les années 90 la
porte de paris de piotr kowalski tout
proche du vélodrome et depuis le mois de
septembre
labellisé patrimoine d'intérêt régional
nous sommes
à proximité de l'autoroute a16 et donc
l'idée des urbanistes à l'époque plutôt
que d'avoir une simple bretelle
d'autoroute qui pénètre dans la ville
nouvelle
l'idée était d'avoir une véritable
entrée de ville marquer comme il se doit
avec cette arche monumental autour d'un
rond point qui permet de distribuer les
les différentes routes d'accès et
notamment l' axe qui se dirige tout
droit vers
vers la place pompidou comme la porte de
paris deux autres avons obtenu ce label
lancé par la région en 2017
trois oeuvres qui ont un point commun la
monumentalité c'est à la fois
un label comme je disais de
reconnaissance et qui montre que ce que
cet art public en partie au patrimoine à
part entière y'a pas de fait finalement
il n'y a pas de petits et de grands
patrimoines et c'est aussi un label qui
permet de mettre l'accent sur cette
particularité des villes nouvelles de
l'art public au sein d'emile nouvelle
qui est quand même une des
caractéristiques assez forte de ses
oeuvres se parle avec un fil conducteur
la bièvre meta de nissim mercado marque
les débuts du canal urbain une oeuvre de
92 qui appelle celle de marta pan à
guyancourt
la perspective qui est une oeuvre de
transition entre la ville et la
compagnie et l'idée en fait des
aménageurs à l'époque de l'établissement
public d'aménagement était de concevoir
ce circuit d'eau en l'accompagnant
d'oeuvres d'art on a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle une étude préalable pour
autour de la perspective de martha pad
pour en étudier la restauration futur
label permet une aide en investissement
pour la restauration et de
fonctionnement pour sa valorisation
saint quentin en yvelines possède 40
oeuvres d'art urbain l'agglomération
réfléchit à mettre en avant les oeuvres
du pôle elancourt mort pas une
célébration onirique de la nature et du
sauvage jusqu'au 17 novembre l'esprit du
cirque plume son parent de la scène
nationale du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les artistes
présentent leurs dernières saisons après
plus de trente ans d'existence
aurélie rose était en répétition une
page est en train de se tourner pour le
pionnier du nouveau cirque
après plus de 35 ans d' aventure le
cirque plume originaire de franche-comté
joue son ultime spectacle au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
leur objectif depuis leur création
célébrer cet art millénaire à leur façon
l'idée c'était de faire un rêve de vivre
la vie qui nous plaisait le plus c'est
la vie itinérante avec un chapiteau de
faire un spectacle de cirque qui nous
permettait de rencontrer toutes les
classes d'âge toutes les classes
sociales dans un spectacle qui pouvait
être conçue comme un poème
acrobatie danse m'a chinois ou encore
numéros comiques pour cette dernière
saison 15 artistes envahissent la scène
au rythme des saisons et célèbrent leur
amour pour la nature
on va traverser des moments de la nature
de la saison de la forêt la forêt qui
est peut-être notre inconscient à tous
de la neige du vent on va traverser des
soleils notre ère c'est un spectacle
comme ça
derrière ce spectacle musical
acrobatique et poétique un message
écologique pour que cette nature mise à
mal ne vivent pas sa dernière saison à
découvrir jusqu'au 17 novembre sur la
scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines culturels
musique plus précisément pour notre
retour dans les archives de la chaîne
cette semaine ça s'est passé revient sur
le premier festival électro organisée au
vélodrome de montigny le bretonneux
c'était en 2010 est le prochain dédié au
genre de step se déroulera le samedi 7
décembre 2019
à partir de 21h
[Musique]
les vélos ont été rangés remplacé par
les platines de dimanche à lundi le
vélodrome nationale a vécu 14 heures de
concert cinq artistes et groupes se sont
succédé
[Musique]
trois heures de 7 pour un état dj
membres du blockhaus un collectif
promouvant la technique ça sort un peu
les gens te revoir dans les clubs déjà
et puis son que
ça va dans la logique de
la démocratisation de la techno d'être
dans des lieux aussi un pouvant
emblématique pour paris c'est important
dans l'air centrale un public venu de
toute la france dont il est le gros saut
de bien sûr mais aussi coup dans caen
lyon paris ou encore marseille gérable
pour m'éclater avec mes potes taper du
pied et s'amuser comme on peut pour
faire la fête on a entendu il y avait
une soirée plutôt façon il y avait des
bons cette heure on est venu tout de
suite on adore la techno tous du coup on
est venu pour vraiment s'éclater toute
la soirée je voulais faire la rare série
qui aida gare saint lazare et j'ai
malheureusement pas pu la terre et j'ai
eu des retours de monstrueux qui était
officines et là j'ai vu là hors série je
me suis dit qu'il fallait absolument que
j'attaque succès donc pour ce deuxième
rendez vous hors série après la gare
saint lazare en septembre dernier près
de 4000 personnes ont dansé jusqu'au
petit matin
[Musique]
on sort des yvelines direction le
triangle de gonesse
[Musique]
après l'abandon de repas city le
gouvernement annonce qu'une mission doit
se tenir pour définir un nouveau projet
une décision qui ne satisfait pas les
élus locaux favorable au complexe de
commerces et loisirs et les militants
opposés à l'urbanisation de la zone
reportage de nos confrères via grand
paris donc c'était le 7 novembre dernier
ce jour là la ministre de la transition
écologique annoncé l'abandon du projet
europa city un méga complexe de
commerces et de loisirs prévu à gonesse
pour 2027
à la place le gouvernement souhaite un
projet alternatif
une mission dans ce sens doit être
conduite par francis rol-tanguy
précédemment en charge du dossier notre
dame des landes
inacceptable pour les élus locaux si
europa city tel qu'il est proposé ne
convient pas peut-être qu'on peut encore
travailler le sujet mais pourquoi tout
d'un seul coup monsieur rol-tanguy vous
avez vu on nous dit vous allez
travailler avec monsieur rol-tanguy très
bien je ne le connais pas ce que je sais
c'est qu'il a fait auparavant
on arrivait à des catastrophes quand
même donc j'aimerais bien ne pas être
mangé la même façon il faut qu'il vienne
ici je le mets au défi oui le pressent
de la république de venir expliquer le
sens de sa décision et de venir
expliquer c'est quoi le projet
alternatif
est ce que c'est un projet renvoyée aux
calendes grecques un projet pour jamais
alors que nous avions un projet pour
demain du côté des militants écologistes
l'abandon de europa city ne signifie pas
la fin de leur mobilisation
le projet devait voir le jour dans un
ensemble plus vaste une zone d'activités
de 280 ha desservi par la ligne 17 du
grand paris express ont tenu à être
présent dimanche sur deux ici sur le sur
le terrain pour empêcher le démarrage du
chantier de la gare
il est impensable pour nous de démarrer
le chantier de la garde puisque le
projet que l'on souhaite c'est le projet
connu maintenant sur le monde et projets
carmat qui est le maintien de
l'agriculture au service de la
population d'île de france
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte sur des
images fortes de l'exposition des
oeuvres de najah al boukai professeur de
dessin syrien dans le cadre de la
semaine des écrivains emprisonnés
persécutés et empêcher retour de
l'actualité dès lundi avec le 7-8
journal weekend sur terry 78
[Musique]
price free
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]